[Music]
it's a secret
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no no thunder chief guys it's done with
unknown actually a hunger key
get out of here keep it out of our way
you're gonna miss me when I'm gone
you're gonna miss me by my walk you're
gonna miss me by my talk oh you're gonna
miss me when I'm gone
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] Chris you can do it I'll buy your
step holy person Tony Danza there's only
one thing that would make this better
it's gonna beim a acting funny but I
don't know why
excuse me you I like it this guy
darling you're so great I can't wait for
you to are you late let's express Eugene
Alison let's get out of here you you
smell like a douche
well like Axe body spray no like an
actual douche you can dance you see that
girl watch that scene dig in the dancing
queen
[Music]
if the metronome do you know Yoshino you
gonna make me spend some money on it you
said oh yeah the party don't stop til I
walk in don't stop make it pop DJ blow
my speakers up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
real G thoroughbred from the streets and
sagging with my grandma dros that means
granny panties drop suck Oh God
yeah
mmm waivers was that God when I was into
pirates where your ass is that when I
was travelling in a stroller stroller
why in the world don't you just a better
rapper I am a fish trapper
your nipples are gently gently wonderful
says here they Teletubbies everybody
will be dancing you're not doing it
right go ahead beat off with a bang yeah
let's go shopping
[Music]
fault and loud and everybody shots turn
down for what
[Music]
these girls a lawyer a lawyer yeah
counterpart they make a lot of money
smart and pretty you should go for it
well who sings that song uh Chris Brown
yeah that's definitely misheard yeah
songs about respecting women the fighter
yeah it's not a Chris Brown so I think I
know Chris Brown all of me
just like animals animals like
animals-mals
[Music]
I'm a dragon let's write it down I love
ya i'm gonna love ya i'm gonna love ya
like a black widow baby become my really
obvious see how that's a really oh yeah
that's a good mister clear yeah no those
are the real works i'll been drinkin
I've been drinkin clip independence got
it well that doesn't make any
grammatical sense at all I mean it's the
song so I mean huh that's stupid
oh my god when kylo Ren that was raising
spoilers sorry sorry yeah who didn't
Grey's parents are okay so you and me we
just don't get along you make me feel
like a Digimon well it's winter should
we go no you stay in the club like what
we be in the party in the club I'm
hungry this joke sucks I'm a [ __ ]
carrots oh my god
I'm a foxing carrots oh that's their
real carrots oh my god again again oh
Jesus one more time and i got this sewed
up no this relationship is broken we
really should get out here you will stay
and sing you watch me I just need one
more shot half again
[Music]
focus fire a gun oh don't tell your
mother fish in the cupboard watch me
watch me ooh watch me now do my stanky
leg oh dude touch me like and dude touch
touch me like a dude remember me
standing in a nice dress staring at the
sunset babe
please welcome to the 1989 World Tour
stage my very best friends
Ashley Perez what's it brother the LMU
leshenka donut me Eugene sorry all right
okay oh um sorry ass carrots oh I ain't
worried man nothing that's not misheard
it's a Caribbean accent Oh jump back no
no it's not you're making it's Beijing
God Chris you're done you'd be a little
racist
I thought we voted the work came with
racism this year
[Music]
all my friends are eatin escape real
school
[Music]
can you guys hurry up watching this on
my bones
it does electric baby when I turn it on
oh is that what I took a pill later
pizza to show up easy yeah cool
oh sorry I don't do drugs yeah cause
I'll be Christmas calm down
oh I don't like either what's up baby
this is what you came for lightning
Triceratops
had said this party on fire
players puja
pinky makers to the whoa legacy fan out
why you see panda packets full damage
salable cannon
[Music]
[Music]
oh my oh my god Wow oh my kid wait can
you I'm in a couple why would I want to
he still got it
[Music]
the only bottle a tremendous bottle a
huge bottle but always loves me waste -
is a masterpiece waist down
she's a masterpiece weights up she's a
four I wouldn't I wouldn't don't need no
butterflies when you give me the whole
damn flu start grooving the Wrath of
Khan girls get loose when they hear the
song you know rat pecan is actually the
best Star Trek film no no it's like
great like a rolls-royce no eraser from
Lord of the Rings have a nice day
do you know what a nozzle allows guys
there no more girls at this party
[Music]
some zombies is there one one Asian baby
I'm white I'd love an Asian baby great
headline oh ha ha oh I am the new
Brangelina
I stopped Lotus but you said you didn't
see her Oh
oh my god up in there all night I got me
one inside you sound too innocent
fancy free song you don't know what the
song is about do you all right yeah just
when you get
that's what our wrist icicle is I'm
gonna start going to church again I
think okay it's oh come on guys that's
too literal cut left this again no more
no why why do we have to do these mr.
lyrics by 2016
see you later
[Music]